hey Jenny how are you good to see you
nice to meet you Selma how are you oh
hello
it's so good to see both of you uh I had
so much fun watching this film the plot
line you know the fact that Selma's
character gets her groove back that's
what it's all about right so Selma you
got to break it down to me either in
words or song for women like me over 40.
what was it like getting the best um
provocative
acrobatic passionate dance from the one
and only Channing Tatum
it was the primary like thank God that's
over uh sort of energy
no no amazing it was amazing
um it was already
honestly it was also amazing
for me because
I've never really done something like
that like right dances but not
connected to somebody like together
so for me it was a new experience
and uh I was surprised that I could do
it I was terrified at the beginning
and uh
he was very easy because
he's patient yeah he likes to empower
women he made me feel uh safe he made me
laugh so that I didn't feel so
ridiculous by laughing at my
Ridiculousness but that is in a loving
way and
I love this song yeah and he was great I
loved it he was great I never ended you
do so I'm gonna confess to you guys I
was like should I tell you guys so I
went to Vegas to interview Harrison Ford
and my friend bought a ticket to Magic
Mike so guys I went by myself sat in the
front row and I ended up on stage with
Magic Mike Vegas
what performance the the main one where
he takes you and throws you on the floor
permission yeah you see you're laughing
so there's some something very funny
about the Ridiculousness of it all you
know
puts joy to it right I mean for you
Channing to have this franchise and
bring that joy to so many people it must
must feel good
no I mean so we did the first movie and
the first movie like someone was like
you guys have to do like a like a Magic
Mike like strip show and I was like
absolutely not that that world is like
super dark and I don't really want
anything to do with that world and then
uh lots of things happen and then and
then we were making we're making the
second one or right before we were about
to make the second one uh Somebody went
to one of the uh shows in Vegas and
they were just like they didn't tell
their boyfriend and this is this is like
a couple that were very they're very
like they don't they don't not share
anything and he she didn't tell him that
that they went to like one of those
shows and uh and he was like
why didn't you tell me like it was weird
that you didn't tell me like he's like
she's like I was embarrassed the show
was so bad it was so offensive and like
I just I just felt silly for going to it
and I didn't I didn't I don't know
didn't feel good and then we started
talking about what
the idea that like those shows like like
um I'll just say Chippendales and all
these all these other ones like they
haven't evolved since they began and
like every every single every single
business has to evolve to like you know
keep going and it just never were asked
to like change and and like I was like
all right well what would be what would
be like yeah yeah but what would it be
now like what would actually be the a
really good show to go to like a good a
good thing to experience and uh and then
we just kind of we went and we just kept
exploring and this is where we landed
something didn't embarrassed the girls
to say they went yeah exactly not well
Selma I didn't tell my husband he
doesn't know you guys are the
so chatty what's your tip on giving the
best dad yeah we do need to wrap
whatever time the best one the best lap
dance what what are your tips
oh man live just laugh give each other a
dancing and laugh as much as you can you
guys are amazing I love this movie
congratulations love you guys thank you
thanks everybody